let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
wow happy hump day
it's wednesday you know what that means
we are live here on youtube twitter and
twitch
let's talk the tony michaels podcast i
am the tony michaels
and we have a great episode today we
have several topics we want to get to
i have an announcement i want to make
about the
special guest episode on friday but
let's let's talk about a few topics
first
and then i'll announce who is going to
be our special guest on friday
and then we'll go into details on each
one of these topics
there's a lot of things going on today i
had a show planned but we kind of had
that torch because you know how the news
goes
there's a school shooting or was a
school shooting in arlington texas at
timber view high school uh i i'm still
not
sure on all the details but it seems
like uh there was four people
uh that were actually shot three went to
the hospital um so it's unclear it seems
like there might have been a fight that
was the result
uh or the the the thing that caused
this shooting there was a scuffle or
something i'm not sure the point is is
that the texas law for the guns is not
working obviously it didn't save anyone
or protect anyone from getting shot in
the timber view high school uh so greg
abbott and ted cruz and the rest of
these texas republicans are [ __ ]
wrong on all measures of that so we'll
go through that because
every so often we have to we have to go
back
back to the issue of guns on this show
because they just can't get their
[ __ ] heads out of their asses on this
issue just like every other issue uh we
found out today that they they found the
zodiac killer so i'm gonna reveal who
who the everyone has their own opinion
of who the zodiac killer is
and of course i have mine and
the authorities
have their opinion and they think it's
someone in particular but we'll go
through that
and we also have uh
ted cruz in the news with the school
shooting and possibly some other news
of who he could be identified as
but he he goes to the border to you know
drum up more [ __ ] because he's not
working as a senator he's just going and
having press conferences in texas at the
border to [ __ ] about biden and not
actually do anything about immigration
you know like
run for a senate seat become a senator
in a state that
borders mexico and you know go to
congress and
try to
have policy discussions with people
about immigration reform that would be
really [ __ ] stupid let's do theatrics
and let's let's please the facebook fans
shall we oh speaking of facebook that's
another topic we want to talk about
there was some testimony about facebook
yesterday
in a senate hearing
so we'll maybe touch on that oh and
speaking of facebook and senate hearings
there was a senate hearing today with
the department of justice and josh
hawley josh i'm not a nazi wink holly
decided to uh
express his opinion about school board
facebook terrorist
so we'll talk about that
and uh let's see what else we have oh
yes we have uh speaking of terrorists
we have the january six select committee
uh subpoenas the deadline is kind of
running short on those things and
apparently grandpa poopypants has
instructed all those people that
received those
subpoenas not to comply
because that's what you do when you're
[ __ ] guilty is not comply and you
obstruct remember no collusion no
obstruction no collusion no obstruction
it is what exactly they say it isn't you
got it so if they say it isn't something
it's that [ __ ] thing that's what it
is
so we're going to run through those
topics but first the first thing i want
to do
is i want to get to who our special
guest is on the episode on friday as you
guys know we go live every wednesday
three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern right here on youtube twitter
and twitch and then i post the podcast
on all the directories apple spotify
google all the direct your most favorite
directories out there we post the
episodes up there but every once in a
while we have a special guest episode
and this week we have a special guest
episode and i've been kind of teasing a
little bit about it in in the streams
and some other things
but i want to announce it here today the
special guest for friday which will air
at three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern on friday same time same place
just a different day so this friday
we're gonna have on actor and comedian
gabe sanchez he's at i am gabe sanchez
on all the social medias and all the
instagrams as long as it's running the
tiki talks and the twitters
so he's not he's at i am gabe sanchez on
all those but i want to play a clip from
the show to give you a sense of what he
talked about because gabe as you know
has all these great political uh
satirical videos that he does there's
sketch videos and most of them just have
him and him going back and forth and he
puts on great costumes he has uh
great settings behind him he puts a lot
of work into these videos most of them
about 60 seconds long and it's probably
days and days and days of work just to
get to the 60 seconds
but they're fantastic and there's tons
of them on instagram tic tac and even on
his twitter but he talked about at one
point we watched one of his don jr
videos and then he kind of explained
how he comes to make some of his videos
and how he appears to be
you know strung out on the on the
columbian chowder the booger sugar as i
like to say so let's watch that clip
for
line
you look great for 40.
eric get out of the trash i told you
that pizza has mold on it
line
this is the best part when he calls for
lime but it's not it's not what you
think it's it's exactly what you think
yeah
so so how do you because man i'm i'm
gonna be honest with you like the makeup
is spot on or maybe it's not makeup how
much coke did you have to do or what did
you have to do to prepare to look like
don junior yeah i set up a whole another
business to just completely expense
those business items you know as
research if you will you know i put in
design you know i'm a designer so i'll
put in design to like different props
like like you saw with the ivermectin
and
hydroxychloroquine and you know all the
different things like i'm putting time
in to like add those little details
because i feel like it enriches the the
video um especially for the viewer uh
and sometimes i'll like hide little
easter eggs in there and for like don jr
you know i'm putting on
uh
it's a combination of burning and the
secret here for anyone who wants to know
the secret is you're burning a cork
and then you're rubbing it on your face
to create that kind of that five o'clock
shadow that beard and then i'm taking
like flower for instance so i'm like
digging through my my girlfriend's like
flower staff just like
putting on my face a lot of people ask
me like how i get my eyes so red and
they're like either you irritated them
that much or you're really on coke
uh but that is another prop that i do um
no like it's all these are all practical
effects there's no like
special effects in these videos um it's
putting stuff in my eyes
putting flower on my face
uh and on my jacket and everything
and again it's to sell
the idea
that um
this is that character in that scenario
and in this one it's it's don jr and
he's trying to make a quick buck by
selling a cameo and
can't quite you know
uh pick up on the joke that he's that
he's a part of
fantastic so so go check out the episode
on friday again we'll air it live at
three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern on youtube twitter and twitch
same time same place just on friday so a
different day and then we'll put it up
on all the directories as well so you
can listen to it but you have to go
watch all gabe's videos again you can
you can see all his content and follow
him on social media
at i am gabe sanchez on instagram tick
tock and twitter so go follow gabe give
him a shout out there watch some of his
content we play several his videos on
the show i won't i won't tease exactly
what videos that way you have to go
watch but that we play some of his
favorite and some of my favorite on the
show so go check that on on friday we
appreciate all the support and while i'm
talking about support go to
thetonymichaels.com uh and get you a
[ __ ] sticker here's here's a [ __ ]
sticker
if you use the promo code podcast you
get 10 off at the off all your whole
order
at the merch store so go to the merch
store at thetonymichaels.com or
store.thetonymichaels.com go check out
all the merch over there anything that
you purchase uh just use the word
podcast for promo code you get 10 off
and all the proceeds will go towards the
podcast here for subscription fees and
publication fees and all the software
and all the fancy things you see you see
we got a new kind of look we're starting
a new look here wanted to change it up a
bit
so we're doing some of those things so
go check out the merch store and help uh
support us as well so let's get down to
all the topics
because this is this is some very very
important news up at the top here with
the zodiac killer apparently they
figured out who the zodiac killer was
and i guess i don't know probably maybe
they found him boarding a plane uh
headed to cancun i mean it's a
possibility right i think that could be
a possibility you know the snow lizard
ted cruz everyone thinks he was a zodiac
killer and if you compare the pictures
of the person who the authorities think
the zodiac killer is which i guess he's
been dead for i don't know like three
years now or something um i don't even
remember his name it was like schmed
schmed schmooze or something like that i
don't know it was
some weird name but
anyways he's he looks very similar it
looks like um ted cruz
uh and and this guy fidel castro and
probably the guy who shot jfk could all
probably be the exact same person or at
least like quadruplets that's probably
what it is they were probably
quadruplets at one point or something
maybe maybe it's a reincarnation type
thing um and speaking of ted cruz that
[ __ ] [ __ ] bag
he did get in front of a microphone
today and make a complete [ __ ] fool
out of himself
who could have thought ted cruz would
say some stupid [ __ ] into a microphone
he goes down to texas he's trying to
talk about the border he's trying to
drum up more [ __ ] instead of going
to washington and doing his [ __ ] job
and passing immigration reform and
getting some sort of immigration reform
instituted in this country that [ __ ]
works that isn't [ __ ] absolutely
[ __ ] broken
the guy goes down and and just points at
the problem says it's your problem not
mine elected officials who's not me you
do something about it
like literally this guy is a united
states senator and one of the largest
border states of mexico he is the
senator he's the sitting [ __ ] senator
from texas he's the guy that would be in
the senate him or john cornyn would be
the guys in the senate saying hey we
need to do something about the border in
my state
on the floor of the senate chamber
where reform and policy can actually be
made so it can be changed because hey
bonehead the executive branch only has
so much leeway here
on instituting policy that you create
through legislation you dumb
[ __ ]
so why don't you why don't you hop
instead of hopping on a plane to cancun
which we all would like that just go to
cancun and [ __ ] stay there or get on
a [ __ ] plane go back to washington
and do your [ __ ] job why don't you
instead of standing in front of a
microphone trying to act like you feel
sorry for people who got shot in high
school because your stupid [ __ ] state
including you think it's a good idea to
give everyone and anyone guns everyone
six-year-olds 12 year olds high
schoolers i mean [ __ ] let's let them
carry them in their backpacks that way
when they get in a scuffle they can just
shoot each other i mean the good guys
with the guns are always always always
going to make sure to get rid of the bad
guys with the guns right because i know
this is going to be their argument this
is always their [ __ ] argument good
guy bad guy [ __ ] uh mental illness [ __ ]
i mean it's always it's always the same
[ __ ] [ __ ] i did a video a long ago a
tic tac long ago about i called it the
mental amendment
because they always do that rather it's
a semi-automatic rifle or it's a [ __ ]
handgun whatever it is when we have one
of these shootings they always trudge
out the same old [ __ ] worn out
[ __ ] [ __ ] arguments of why we
can't have gun control when they should
just say hey we want to make sure gun
manufacturers can sell you guns and a
lot of them and we don't and they pay us
money to make sure they can sell you
guns that's what it is it has nothing to
do with safety has nothing to do with
protection that's all [ __ ] if they
would just say that i would be okay with
it i would be okay like oh okay you are
[ __ ] idiots but they give all these
stupid [ __ ] excuses that don't make
any [ __ ] sense i believe that
americans are [ __ ] tired of this
[ __ ] completely [ __ ] tired of
this [ __ ]
these [ __ ] arguments that have no
[ __ ] logic or critical thinking when
it comes to guns or anything else for
that matter because we're gonna see josh
holly make a [ __ ] fool of himself
today about school about these facebook
school board domestic terrorists that
are running around and running rampant
throughout our country in our
communities
and they're
they're terrorizing uh elected officials
and also [ __ ] hospitals doctors and
nurses for crying out loud it's the same
[ __ ] doing the same [ __ ]
they're terrorists they're domestic
terrorist is what they are they're using
intimidation and terrorist tactics to
try to move the ball in their direction
but
i want to play a clip here of ted cruz
because he was in texas today because he
was trying to talk about the border
and he tries to have i don't know it's
[ __ ] weird i don't know if he's
trying to do a moment of silence or
or what he really he didn't have a very
good
he obviously had a speech written of the
the toxic rhetoric about the immigration
and the border that he wanted to spew
into a microphone so we got the facebook
fans all riled up that way maybe he
could appear on tucker carlson or sean
hannity tonight and get a clip of
himself puking into a [ __ ] microphone
if [ __ ] fascist that's that's exactly
what he was trying to do but then this
school shooting happened and god damn it
that inconvenience is ted cruz because
now he's got to go on the fly and kind
of make up some [ __ ] and look
disingenuous i mean god damn that that
isn't good for politics i just i just
want to get the [ __ ] the highlights
on fox news the oan highlights the
newsmax highlights i want to please the
facebook fans but let's watch the
[ __ ] clip of this [ __ ]
and there have been far too many of
these at far too many schools and so
we are grateful for the courage and the
heroism the first responders
uh and we are hopeful that that all of
the students
or individuals
who may have been injured will come
through
and survive
we're here today
because of the biden border crisis
that continues to rage on the southern
border
so horrible horrible transition there
from ted cruz of course
because he again he had this [ __ ]
speech all written out to puke into the
microphone so that he could get the
facebook fans all riled up and then get
his highlight uh you know his highlight
reel on fox news or
wherever wherever the [ __ ] or maybe
he'll get a [ __ ] interview on on
on steve bannon's war room or some [ __ ]
that [ __ ] [ __ ] box
but here he is here he is he can't he
can't put together a thought about the
the shooting in texas like he can't put
a logical thought together about this
this school shooting in texas because
the reason why is because he's
supporting guns for everybody everybody
should have guns so it's tough to make
the argument at this point to say well
no it's a good thing that everybody had
a gun because that way they were able to
shoot somebody
but trust me they'll work their way into
the good guy bad guy [ __ ] and then it'll
evolve into
a personal protection and then it'll
evolve into oh well the person with the
gun was mentally ill
i mean and that's the problem it's
mental illness is the [ __ ] it ain't
the gun it ain't the gun
it's the mental illness that that killed
whoever or shot and injured whoever or
caused someone to go into a school with
a firearm and and shoot someone
not the law in texas where anyone and
everyone
can get a gun i mean god damn right now
it is easier to get a [ __ ] gun and
kill a human being in texas real
pro-life there pro-lifers but but a
woman can't make sure to protect her
family her her body and her choice nope
can't do that so much [ __ ] easier to
get a goddamn gun than it is to [ __ ]
get a medical procedure that might save
your life or might help your family
or might be your body your choice you
might embody my choices i i'm not
waiting on them to do the my body your
choice on the guns i'm sure it's coming
i'm sure it's coming the hypocrisy is
there the the uh
uncoupling from critical thinking is
already there so i did a video uh and
it's i mean it's probably been back in
uh february uh it was when we had a mass
shooting and and it was with a a
semi-automatic assault style rifle which
the same same premise as a handgun which
it sounds like a handgun might have been
used in this there i i haven't been able
to keep up because i've been working on
the podcast today of if they have
announced what gun the last report i saw
they hadn't determined what gun it is
but it doesn't [ __ ] matter it doesn't
matter it doesn't
matter
and if we make it matter then it's going
to matter it shouldn't [ __ ] matter it
doesn't matter
it doesn't matter
so let me play the video that i it's
called mental
mental amendment it's one of my [ __ ]
walking rants so let's play that what
are you [ __ ] mental let's talk a week
here in america and we have another mass
shooting we've already started through
the progression of the arguments of the
republicans of why we can't regulate
semi-automatic rifles first things first
guns don't kill people people kill
people you know like drunk drivers and
[ __ ] they do know that you have to have
a license to drive right jesus [ __ ]
crate on the list you can't take my guns
because you can't take my whiteness you
ever heard of felons let's work our way
on down to the next one tyrannical
government [ __ ] shit-eating morons
have heard of tanks drones and nuclear
weapons right next it's an individual
right then why does it say a regulated
militia hmm personal protection who has
these type of [ __ ] enemies hunting
because i gotta use it for hunting
because those whitetail are heavily
armed last but not least we've reached
the stage of mental illness is the
problem [ __ ] boneheads realize that
everyone has a certain degree of mental
illness but not everyone owns
semi-automatic [ __ ] rifles
[ __ ] them
[Laughter]
so it applies here and the point is is
that this is going to be their
progression of why it is okay that this
school shooting happened and that it's
not the it's not it's not because we
can't have decent policy on guns to
prevent this type of [ __ ] from happening
they're gonna run through that argument
that's that's the the progression of the
argument always always always with these
[ __ ]
every mother [ __ ] time
and and it's
it the hypocrisy is astounding and me
and gabe in in friday's episode the
special guest episode we talk a lot
about hypocrisy and and kind of where
his his
his inspiration comes from and that's
where it comes from the the [ __ ] gqp
hypocrisy
all of it the whole nine yards and we
see it we see it with the [ __ ]
facebook testimony
we see it with the [ __ ] facebook
testimony
jesus christ
here is a whistleblower who worked not
only for facebook this isn't like
someone that facebook found off the
street
she's got degrees in data science and
she goes out and she works for google
she works for pinterest she works for
several really big
social media platforms and then she goes
over to facebook and she realizes when
she's seeing these internal memos that
facebook knows they're harming people
not that facebook everybody knows
facebook and social media at it at some
extent harms human beings we know it and
that's the reason why is because human
beings are garbage we're [ __ ] garbage
human beings are [ __ ] garbage if we
haven't figured that out in the last
year and a half with this pandemic i
don't know what you figured out i don't
know what the [ __ ] i don't know where
you've been or what you've been paying
attention to but there's a certain
percentage of human beings that are
absolute [ __ ] trash
trish trish
trish
and the trashiest of the trashiest of us
are on facebook encouraging them to be
more garbage than the next piece of
garbage
just
trumpster fire after trumpster fire
after trumpster fire
the last five [ __ ] years it's getting
exhausting
and this whistleblower
provides evidence
not only not only that facebook knows
they're harming uh certain groups of
teenage girls and other and other
demographics they know they they [ __ ]
know
that they're harming these people and
they continue
to contin with the profitable harmful
acts
that they're committing that they know
they're committing this is very similar
with the tobacco companies i talked
about it yesterday on the live stream on
twitch
by the way we do a live stream on twitch
every once while go download the twitch
app and follow us over there
but yesterday i talked about this
because we were streaming some of the
testimony that the facebook uh
whistleblower
hogan is her name her last name gave
yesterday to the senate
and several senators blumenthal and
marky and a few others
gave the analogy and i even gave the
analogy yesterday that it is very
similar to how congress
took a flyswatter to the tobacco and the
cigarette companies in this country
back in the 90s because the reason why
is it the the reason why it's similar
not because the products are similar
facebook doesn't give you cancer i mean
unless you see misinformation that would
make you act out in a seditious and
trees in this way
and and become a domestic terrorist
cancer it is a cancer on society but not
in your body
right and it isn't harming your physical
health just your mental health
they've lost their minds they bless
their [ __ ] minds
so the comparison to the tobacco
companies and the way congress regulated
the tobacco companies on how they market
is very very similar and the reason why
is because tobacco companies were
roughed up in the 90s because they knew
they knew their marketing
was targeting people who they were
harming they knew it
it's not like some oh well yeah of
course cigarettes are bad for you they
make you cough they can give you cancer
they can make you sick but ah you know
who cares if you mark it in every single
corner of every single thing and
cartoons to kids and on and on and on it
went to to
make people think that cigarettes were
okay it wasn't that tobacco companies
like hey we got this really
this really great product that gives you
kind of a high but it might kill you and
it might make you sick and it's probably
harmful to you so here try it out nope
that's not what they were doing like
all that stuff you see about cigarettes
being bad ah don't pay attention to that
be cool be joe cool be the marlboro man
be cool they knew they knew their
message was the opposite of what their
product was doing
and they knew it it's fraud it's [ __ ]
fraud
the same way facebook is committing
fraud now facebook's probably not the
only social media platform uh they they
claim because facebook owns instagram
and whatsapp but the instagram got a lot
of attention yesterday in the hearing
because
because they're targeting young girls
and a lot of these young girls are
believing this marketing and getting
into a rabbit hole of anorexia sometime
leading to depression
and
even suicide
facebook knows this
they know this that their product
can have deadly consequences
and they continue to do what they're
doing and that is enough for me and for
congress it should be and this country
republican democrat i don't give a [ __ ]
who you are to say okay it's time to
have a social media regulatory body
that can regulate social media not just
facebook
not just instagram now now they
obviously are the culprits on the
chopping block here but we have a lot of
social media channels out there that are
spreading more misinformation than even
facebook and instagram it's just that
their reach is so [ __ ] far and it
reaches into every single person in
society almost because even if you're
not on facebook the place that you work
everyone else is on facebook and when
you go there and they're like hey i read
on the ivermectin institute group that
you should take iomet and drink benadine
and and hydroxychloroquine and clorox
bleaching your brain and i know i don't
[ __ ] know what they're saying
they're talking about [ __ ] doing oil
change on your blood and [ __ ]
and then what they're doing
then what they're doing on these
ivermectin institute groups because
remember we are at the intersection of
wrestlemania and real life
we are at i keep saying this and i'm
gonna keep pounding this drum we are at
the intersection of wrestlemania and
real life and on one corner there's the
ivermectin institute and on the other
corner there's the domestic terrorist
training camp
excuse me excuse me the concerned the
concerned citizen
the concern as josh hollywood say that
[ __ ]
josh hawley calling school board
facebook terrorism concerned parents get
the [ __ ]
out of here you you [ __ ] [ __ ] box you
lying sack of [ __ ] [ __ ] that
[ __ ] would take two seconds two
seconds to realize that people are
organizing on these social media groups
not just facebook but facebook and these
ivermectin institute type
groups
they're organizing to go to school
boards that aren't even theirs
and to to threaten them with violence
and to intimidate school board members
with death threats threatening them to
never go into public
it's it's it's
josh
listen joshie
there's a thing called a video camera on
a phone and also most almost all most of
these school board meetings are recorded
you know that right like the these these
insurrectionists these domestic
terrorists these maga trump pump and
evangelical facebook
terrorist that you're supporting these
timothy mctrump humpers that you're
defending that are going and yelling
garbage that they read on a facebook
thread literally that's what they're
doing they're going and reading a
facebook thread
that they read it's just like slam
queueing on poetry [ __ ]
that they're
spewing into the school board microphone
that's causing the school board to have
to concentrate on all kinds of other
[ __ ] that they shouldn't have to
concentrate on they should be
concentrated on the education of
children
their safety at this point they did this
all last year folks all last year these
schools had mass mandates they had they
had mitigation mandates in the schools
and these people said [ __ ] nothing
there was no [ __ ] clamoring there was
no insurrection at these schools because
that's really what it is they can't
commit an insurrection at the capitol to
overthrow the government with a cheeto
dust coup so now they're gonna try the
cheeto dust coup in the back door and
steve bannon is the one who's trying to
[ __ ] stoke this [ __ ] this backdoor
cheeto dust kangaroo koo [ __ ] by taking
over school boards and
governments but listen folks they're not
taking over the [ __ ] school boards
half these people don't even vote
and they don't even or if they do vote
they don't even vote in the goddamn
school district that they're going to to
terrorize these school board meetings
these people are organizing and hopping
town to town
school district to school district to
look to look like it's a fraud just like
everything else that's trumpian it's a
[ __ ] fraud to try to shut these
school boards down and change their
policies
on safety
and disease mitigation when they should
be focused on [ __ ] education leave
them the [ __ ] alone here's what i think
school boards to do i think school board
should say we're going here's what we're
going to do we're going to virtually
broadcast
our school board meeting we are elected
officials this is elec this is official
business that we are elected to do we
are bound by an oath and a duty to do
this business this is official business
meeting folks they do not have to let
these [ __ ] in if they're going
to cause trouble like that they do not
have to let them in you just close your
meetings broadcast them live so everyone
can see them
everyone can see them on on
social media or circuit tele close
circuit television wherever the [ __ ] you
need to go to see the school board
meeting
and then you can submit comments through
email afterwards [ __ ] you
that's what i'd say we're concentrating
on education now you [ __ ] can yell and
scream about mass because here's what's
going to happen these vaccine mandates
are going to come right up the pike here
next year
california is already doing it gavin
newsom's already said we're doing
[ __ ] vaccine mandates we're doing it
and it's going to be state after state
after state after state
they're all going to do it and they're
all going to win every last one of them
they can't win one of these [ __ ] mass
in florida texas missouri
eric schmidt went on a tirade with a
school board here in missouri
when they wanted a mass mandate spent
the state's [ __ ] money
twice he spent the states money on his
case and then he spent the school board
which is a [ __ ] state elected board
for that [ __ ] district in the state
spent their money that state money
to defend themselves over something he
knew he was going to lose eric schmidt
you dumb [ __ ] and the only
reason why he's doing it and the only
reason why these republicans are doing
it is because they're trying to keep
this trumpism going
these trump these trump humping
timothy mctrump bumpers these
evangelical manga q and honors are
trying to make sure that in 2022 they
had platforms to run on and the only way
they can win is to stoke their voters to
go to the polls and the only way they
can get their voters to the polls is to
be scared of the democrat the
blood-sucking cabal the the the
fouchialchid the virus
they're going to try to continue this
[ __ ]
and josh hawley is only trying that's
what he's trying to do in this hearing
today and i'm going to play the clip
here where he's questioning a doj
official and he's totally he's told he's
gaslighting he's gaslighting and he's
trying to get again he's trying to get
the highlight clip
on fox news oan newsmax he's trying
to to appease the facebook fans at the
intersection of wrestlemania in real
life and they're they're walking across
the intersection from the ivermectin
institute to the domestic terrorism
training camp excuse me the concerned
citizen training camp because let's face
it josh hawley josh holly thinks the
insurrectionist we're tourist
now he thinks the the school board
facebook domestic terrorists are
expressing their concerns they're
concerned
parents they're expressing their
concerns so i'm sure that josh hawley
would think that the nazis were just
cleaning up the neighborhood you
[ __ ] fascist
let's watch and let's see what the
fascist has to say in his little
questioning
[ __ ]
parents
waiting sometimes for hours to speak at
a local school board meeting to express
concerns about critical race theory
or the masking of their students
particularly young children
is that in and of itself is that
harassment and intimidation is waiting
to express one's view at a school board
meeting harassment and intimidation as
the attorney general's memorandum made
quite clear spirited debate is welcome
is a hallmark of this country um it's
something we all should engage in i
don't think so it was monaco with all
due respect it didn't make it quite
clear it doesn't define those terms nor
does it define harassment or
intimidation it talks about violence i
think we can agree that violence
shouldn't be condoned or looked aside
from in any way swept under the rug at
all
but harassment and intimidation what do
those terms mean in the context of a
local school board meeting i mean this
seems to in the first amendment context
we talk about the chill the chill to
speech if this isn't a deliberate
attempt to chill
parents
from showing up at school board meetings
for their elected school boards i don't
know what is i mean i'm not i'm not
aware of anything like this in american
history we're talking about the fbi
you're using the fbi to intervene in
school board meetings that's
extraordinary senator i have to
respectfully disagree that is not what
point me to an instance the
the attorney general's memorandum um
made quite clear that
violence is not appropriate spirited
public debate on a whole range of issues
is absolutely what this country is all
about um
then why is it being investigated by the
fbi it is not when and if
any
situation turns to violence then that is
the appropriate role of law enforcement
to address it
now obviously
josh hawley has not
watched
one goddamn clip from some of these
school board meetings because they're
not just waiting josh hawley to be heard
that's all [ __ ] [ __ ] there may be
some meetings out there where parents
are waiting they have their statements
prepared they come up they give a
reasonable argument a reasonable
statement they're not threatening people
they're not they're not spreading
outright [ __ ] lies the school board
the elected school board has the duty to
make sure that people are not coming to
the microphone and spreading [ __ ]
lies at their official meeting
these meetings are official meetings
they go into record they're taking
[ __ ] they're taking [ __ ] notes on
these goddamn things
these are official business government
business for us now when i mean us i
mean whoever lives in that school
district who voted for those people
whose kids go to that school
it is it is that elected bodies duty to
make sure that the information that's
being told at a school board meeting an
official an official [ __ ]
meeting
that it's truthful that it's not
misinformation it's not [ __ ] lies
they have a duty so they should do their
duty now what the doj is saying and if
you read the memorandum and what she's
saying to him which i wish she would
have slam dunked his ass a little better
what they're saying is hey
if if there is
cases where you're intimidating and
harassing
public elected officials with violence
we will prosecute because it's against
the [ __ ] law
to threaten
an elected official with violence
you cannot intimidate or threaten them
with violence
death threats
uh saying you can't come out in public
we're gonna physically remove you
that is not how it works
see that's why these people don't like
democracy that's why they don't like it
they don't like democracy because
democracy gave them a school board that
they're convinced is part of the
blood-sucking cabal because it's not
doing what the ivermectin institute on
facebook is telling them they should do
oh josh holly says you're me they're
making children wear masks yeah because
children can't get vaccinated and a lot
of parents don't want their [ __ ] kids
to get sick needlessly
it's really [ __ ] stupid it's really
[ __ ] stupid to get a to get thousands
and thousands of kids sick needlessly
when we know what works we did it all
year last year you realize that right
before we had the vaccine before we had
it
we did this last year with the mask and
mitigation tactics social distancing and
it worked it worked it [ __ ]
worked so why why now why now well now
there's nothing to divide besides this
and the fascist josh hawley steve bannon
donald trump
people like uh uh steve's art excuse me
dan scavino
who isn't appearing before the january
six
uh select commit or isn't complying with
their subpoenas apparently they can't
even find the guy have you heard this
maybe they're not even they're not even
able to find
dan scavino a skip town i think what
they should do
is probably check grandpa poopypants his
diaper drawer i know he's like in new
jersey now so
maybe maybe he's maybe he's in
mar-a-lago hiding in
in in the mango mussolini's closet
i i don't know
it could be he could have be all the way
crawled up in his ass
i mean maybe he's hiding
in the cheeto dust mobster's ass
because apparently the cheeto dust
mobster is is throwing out orders
on these subpoenas these select
committee subpoenas
there's uh four in particular
that they're terrified of
steve bannon
uh patel
uh mark meadows and uh the deputy chief
the deputy chief of staff which mark
mendel's was the chief of staff at the
time but the deputy chief of staff dan
scavino and apparently dan scavino is
nowhere to be found well you know what
when someone is being uh subpoenaed by
congress the unfortunate part is there
is laws that can make it criminal which
i don't know maybe the doj should not
only look in the school board meetings
but maybe they should look into uh some
of these
congressional hearings for the january 6
where people aren't appearing and aren't
complying with subpoenas and aren't even
aren't even making themselves available
to be served that subpoena because
here's the thing they think i i i know
this is i know this is uh the buffoon in
chief
the cheeto dust mobster i know this is
his thought process he's like well if
they can't serve you if they can't serve
you the subpoena
then it doesn't exist and you can't be
subpoenaed if they can't it doesn't
matter
it doesn't matter it doesn't it doesn't
matter the congressional subpoena is
completely enforceable rather rather you
work whether you jump out of donald
trump's ass to be served or not it's
[ __ ] enforceable you dumb
[ __ ] it's completely enforceable
just like any other warren or subpoena
is out there
they can enforce this
and they should they should give
criminal referrals because at this point
it does look like obstruction and the
reason why it looks like obstruction is
because the cheeto dust mobster is
telling them to obstruct
he's apparently
got his troops in line the four troops
that are on the chopping block here and
he's telling them to destruct and dan
scavino is the one who's completely
terrified so i would imagine i would
imagine that dan scavino
what we're going to find out about these
january select committees and the
information that they're going to gather
rather they have to go through the
criminal courts to get these subpoenas
enforced or they just use the
sergeant-at-arms inside the congress to
enforce these subpoenas uh because they
should jail these [ __ ] that's
what they should do at this point if
you're hiding information on on
on
a plan that eastman had
that the trump-humping eastman had
that they tried to commit an
insurrection that was the [ __ ] plan
was to stall the vote
and they didn't care by what means they
stole the vote even with violence and
death even if they had to kill because
they were they were going to try to kill
mike pence it's already proven we've
seen that in federal court
there are there there is plenty of
evidence to know that these people their
plan was to go to the extent to stall
this for him and there was coordination
somewhere
somewhere there was coordination
we're gonna find out with who
and that's what these sabines are gonna
sniff out because i don't believe i
believe that the the criminal referrals
for the subpoenas are not even close
to the amount of criminal referrals that
are going to come out of this [ __ ]
select committee there are going to be
mountains of criminal referrals
and it's not going to just end
with a few congressmen or a few people
on donald trump staff
i mean you got to be really paying
attention to what's going on here
that
that there's four people who are very
close to the president that had that had
to do with planning
that had to do with planning of the
january section six insurrection
that the cheeto dust kangaroo coup as i
call it attempt
that they are obstructing
congress at this point which is
completely within the bounds of a
criminal referral and that's what they
should do
they should lock these [ __ ] up
until they comply that's what they
should do just like they did all the
insurrectionist they did the same thing
to the insurrections they locked them up
lock them up
[ __ ] them
[ __ ] them
make them comply
whatever you got to do
now rather you do it through the
sergeant-at-arms inside the congress or
you give the criminal referral to the
department of justice
and you get you get the the doj involved
i mean the doj is going to be involved
in this select committee eventually
and if anyone's of the notion that the
dod j doesn't have some of the goods
on some of the people that are going to
be outed in the select committee because
that's the slow walk here the slow walk
is the select committee doesn't want to
affect
possibly an fbi investigation
that could cause an indictment and a
conviction of someone who was
who who who tried to commit sedition and
maybe even treason
through this insurrection and planning
the insurrection so it's a slow walk and
the other reason why they're slow
walking this
is because which they don't have time to
slow walk it but they are as slow as
they can possibly get it
because the other reason why they're
slow walking it is what they want to do
is they want to make sure that they that
they undo the trump chaos machine little
by little by little by little
and they're doing that i mean we had
jesse benton being charged with taking a
hundred thousand dollars in 2016
with a quid pro quo for a meeting at a
trump fundraiser with a russian
they funneled a hundred thousand dollars
and a bunch of it's gone they don't even
know where the hell it went hmm i wonder
whose pocket that ended up in hmm i
wonder who i wonder who the [ __ ] that
could be
about 75 000 of it probably has cheeto
dust stains all over or maybe just
remnants of
of don junior's fingernail clippings
with booger sugar attached to them i
don't know maybe possibly i'm just
saying
it's surmising i'm coming up with ideas
here just snowballing you know i don't
know
but it seems kind of obvious
it seems kind of obvious that what
they're doing is trying to obstruct the
select committee
with these subpoenas and it's all coming
from
the cheeto dust mobster grandpa
poopypants
mango mussolini jesus
that's where it's coming from
and the reason why it's coming from
there is because he's trying to hide
something
it's it's not [ __ ] complicated it
really isn't we've seen this time and
time again with this [ __ ] fool we've
seen it with the 2016 with the mueller
investigation
at every [ __ ] turn he obstructed and
obstructed and obstructed him and how we
know he obstructed is he kept saying no
obstruction
and how we know he colluded he said no
collusion no obstruction no collusion no
obstruction no collusion which means
there was plenty of collusion
and plenty of obstruction we could see
the obstruction right out in plain day
and now we know there's now we know
there's some sort of collusion they are
at least quid pro quo a hundred thousand
dollars so that way a russian could meet
with donald trump at a fundraiser in
philadelphia
pennsylvania i believe i don't know if
it's filmed it was in pennsylvania i
believe i believe that's i think that's
the fact
you fact checkers out there
grab that fact and see
but allegedly a hundred thousand dollars
went from a russian
to jesse benton who was on the trump
campaign they finally through the
campaign and donald trump in payment of
that hundred thousand dollars was
supposed to meet with a russian
at a fundraiser
and that oh and that's not conclusion oh
okay well that's [ __ ] illegal
jesse bitten
and uh and uh his doug weed i guess
that's his accomplice here doug weed and
what's crazy about the jesse benton case
and if you're not paying attention if
you're not paying attention to that case
you're not seeing the crux of this
you're not seeing where this slow walk
is headed
because jesse benton doesn't just end at
the 2016 campaign
it doesn't end there
grandpa poopypants the buffoon in chief
about a month before he leaves office
gives jesse benton
a [ __ ] pardon for a federal charge
that he was convicted on for bribery in
iowa
during the 2000 and during the 2012
primaries republican primaries when he
was bribing people and convicted of it
to support ron paul not rand paul not
that [ __ ] bag
papa papa [ __ ] bag
ron paul
and then this guy goes to work on his
daddy's [ __ ] bag son rand paul
shitbox jr
goes and works on his campaign and even
mitch mcconnell huh
bribery
campaign bribery so like he's an expert
like he's got you know
he's got
he's bona fide right
he's bona fide for campaign campaign fun
bribery
he's got the credentials
and the conviction to go along with it
cool
so now he gets caught getting a hundred
thousand dollars well
donald trump knew that jesse benton got
that hundred thousand dollars surely
he had to have known that he was meeting
with someone because they were getting a
hundred thousand dollars and he had to
have known where he is meeting and who
he was meeting with
he had to have he was supposed to meet
with this guy
it's not like they were doing a hundred
thousand dollars to pay for rudy's
dripping hair dye
and anti-fart medicine and his [ __ ]
scotch whiskey no
no
no
it was for a meeting with donald trump
so he knew about it he knew about it
that's that's what the court documents
say it was a meeting with donald trump
the cheeto dust mobster
so that doesn't end there though
because donald trump knows that jesse
benton knows this and donald trump knows
he's not going to be the president on
january 20th more than likely as long as
his cheeto dust coupe doesn't take off
he's probably not going to be present on
january 20th he wants to make sure to
protect his ass you know and do another
quid pro quo jesse benton and donald
trump really like these you give me this
i'll give you that quid pro quo [ __ ]
because jesse benton gets a pardon why
would he get a pardon he's already
served his sentence and he's he's
committing other briberies so what's the
hell is the difference what does he need
a pardon for well maybe it was a payment
maybe it was a payment to plead not
guilty to the charges donald trump knew
he would face
because they knew that that the federal
prosecutors was on to him about a
hundred thousand dollars because he knew
that it existed and the evidence existed
it is not hard to [ __ ] keep coloring
in the lines in the color book
i mean jesus christ this is this is
easier than a dot to dot in the coloring
book in the trunk coloring book
it's really [ __ ] simple
donald trump pardoned jesse benton to
keep his [ __ ] mouth shut about the
russian case when he got indicted if
donald trump wasn't the president to
pardon him from that indictment
or to or to prevent that indictment by
by bullying and obstructing
his a.g
whoever that was
rather it was going to be billboard or
not at that point i don't think it was
billboard when he was doing uh
pardons and i'm not sure
which it was
who was the acting attorney general or
the attorney general but someone if
donald trump was going to be president
was going to be the acting attorney
general because they were all acting
they're all acting like they were
attorney general even rather they were
they were confirmed by the congress by
the senate or not they were [ __ ]
acting like they were attorney generals
they were donald trump's nazi foot
soldiers is what they were
and we see it here we see it with the
foot soldiers not complying with the
subpoenas mark meadows steve bannon
patel we have dan scavino not even
seeming to be on the face of the earth
he's gone poof magic doesn't even exist
invisible
so we will see if we can get criminal
criminal charges or criminal referrals
or use the doj to compel these [ __ ]
morons to do what they're supposed to do
and it seems like that all the members
even the republican members
uh adam kisinger and liz chaney are
willing to use the criminal system to
make sure that these people comply with
these congressional subpoenas
for what appear to be crimes
because that's what it appears to be and
that's probably why they're afraid to
even comply with these subpoenas it's
because they know they're going to go
and just plea the fifth in front of
congress
fifth fifth fifth fifth they're going to
plea the fifth
if they don't they self-incriminate
themselves
but the evidence that congress draws up
rather they comply or not
because apparently there's already
people giving depositions to congress
that are witnesses to january 6.
but if we if if we see that evidence and
and congress has that evidence the
select committee has that evidence
that bipartisan committee has that
evidence they can they can submit
criminal referrals rather the nazi the
trump nazi foot soldiers show up and
give and comply with their subpoenas or
not
that's that's what can happen
it can go that way it can go that way
and again i know it's a slow walk and a
lot of people want someone just to go
kick down the door and
arrest donald trump and have it over
with
but there's a lot of fronts here because
there was a lot of criming it wasn't
just january 6 in the insurrection the
seditious insurrection and the planning
of a seditious insurrection where they
were trying to commit a cheeto dust
kangaroo coup
with eastman's plan that he laid out his
memo that he laid out his memorandum i
mean he was trying to give him a road
map on how to steal the united states
constitution and wipe your ass with it
he's like no there's a loophole where
the constitution doesn't mean a goddamn
thing you can just roll it up wipe your
ass with it throw it away and you're the
dictator
and he tried to lay it all out [ __ ] he
was in the oval office talking to him
and then eastman appears on the stage
with giuliani yelling into the
microphone yes commit a coup
the constitution doesn't mean a goddamn
thing
which the only thing that is tethered to
the truth uh to me with eastman's
memorandum that i can tell is that the
the [ __ ] the [ __ ] certification is
all theatrics anyways it's just a big
ceremony
apparently in this in this meeting in
the oval office where mike pence
and eastman and donald trump are in
eastman's telling pence because pence is
asking eastman well i don't even have
that power and eastman says i don't
think you have it either it's all
ceremonial it really there is no power
this this joint session isn't going to
give you any power at all because it
doesn't exist
it's just ceremonial
the states certify the votes the states
the states certify the votes
that's what gives us a president it
doesn't matter what congress thinks
about it
that's all [ __ ]
that's all [ __ ] it's all [ __ ]
theater ceremony all it is is people
reading who won the oscar they done won
the oscar
they done won it they got the oscar
it's just the ceremony the pomp and
circumstance of it all even if the
oscars didn't happen that person would
still get a trophy you got it you follow
me on january 20th donald trump's
constitutional presidency was ending at
noon
on january 20th he was not going to be
the president and someone was going to
be sworn in as president because that's
the constitutional duty
of the chief justice of the supreme
court
that's his duty he took an oath he was
going to swear someone in now rather it
was joe biden who was the certified
winner or they didn't know who the
certified winner was because mike plants
and his head fly decided to to overthrow
the constitution of the united states
and cause chaos and whatever the [ __ ] it
was
they would just use the constitution to
decide who the next president was and it
wasn't gonna be donald trump it would be
nancy pelosi she's a speaker of the
house you [ __ ] boneheads just
and eastman knew this
eastman knew this but they continued
this charade anyways because they wanted
to appear gran appease grandpa poopy
pants because he's a whiny little
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and they had to appease the facebook
fans because they're whiny little
[ __ ] snowflake [ __ ]
manga trump humping evangelical spread
knicks
the facebook ivermecton institute
domestic terrorist
god damn i can't even you people are
[ __ ] adding so many goddamn
descriptions i can't keep up anymore i
can't even tweet out the the description
with 180 characters with all the [ __ ]
descriptions for you stupid bastards
anymore
it's getting ridiculous you people are
so untethered from reality
pluck
your head
out of your [ __ ] ass
all of you
on guns on school shootings on school
board meetings unmasked on vaccine on
[ __ ] disease mitigation
on your [ __ ] mango mussolini cheeto
dust monster grandpa poopy pants cheeto
dust kangaroo coo where you tried to
overthrow our democracy
and [ __ ] on the constitution of the
united states and take away all the
liberty from all the people who voted
for trump or against trump
so you know what you know what i have to
say
[ __ ] them
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them